we learned how omics data can be used to
reveal the biological complexity of over
19 rupees but how does bioinformatics
come into play during this process
and what are some other areas where
bioinformatics analysis is used
so now we will hear from dr suchi to
understand the role of bioinformatics in
omega study
dr shuchi nagar is working as an
associate professor at diy partel
biotechnology bioinformatics institute
pune she did her phd from department of
chemical technology university of
calcutta in the field of chem
informatics and drug design she has 17
publications to her credit she has
guided around 20 project students
presently she has two funded projects
one is related to designing anti-cancer
drugs and the other is designing quorum
sensing individuals
further her expertise is also being
applied for studying alzheimer's
diseases and for generating iron vedic
formulation
we are pleased to have you with us dr
shuchin over to you you may share your
screen now
okay so before i start off with this
topic of relevance of bioinformatics in
movies i would like to just introduce my
institute where i am working
and
just to give a brief the courses that
are offered in our institute is we have
v-tech with biotechnology we tech with
medical biotechnology
uh we've just started with btec with
artificial intelligence and data science
there's mtech biotechnology and msc
biotechnology so these are the reports
that are being offered at our institute
and we have different research areas
that are there which are
very functional and there's a lot of
research done on these areas
uh it's microbial diversity then you
have plant and environmental
biotechnology you have genetics and
molecular biology
cancer and transformational research
protein biochemistry and bioinformatics
so these are the six broader areas on
which
all the faculties of our institute are
working
and it is uh
we really have a good strength of
faculties who are working and doing
really well in all these fields
now to start with the topic of uh
relevance of um you know bioinformatics
in comics
i just want to say that uh when we talk
of comics or when we are talking about
bioinformatics it's like saying that
what has come first has the hen come
first or the egg has come first that's
because it is uh a part of omix and part
of bioinformatics that is common so you
have certain part of comics wherein uh
that part of the mix is uh you know
completely done on wet lab then you have
the data that is generated is stored in
certain databases so you collect those
data from there
and then you use the different
bioinformatics tools to analyze them so
that is why we can uh you know it's very
difficult to say whether bioinformatics
came first or omics came first so it's
the same story like hen came first or
your egg came first
so we can also say it in this way that
so it's like
you know the omics and the
bioinformatics are coming together
joining hands to give you a good
information that will further help us in
systems biology so systems reality is
basically when we are trying to study
different pathways that are there in
very details
and followed with system biology we can
go to studying or doing chemo
informatics studies where we can go
ahead with
designing of new
molecules you know that could be lead
molecules for a particular disease of
interest or a particular target of
interest that we have
so to
just understand the flow chart that is
there with it
what we actually do is this is your
comics part that is there wherein we are
doing certain kind of your
um
you can say experimental works you have
m number of different experimental works
through which you can get data so all
these could be gene data genome data it
can be rna data can be protein it can be
any kind of data depending on what
um
what kind of your
experiment are you doing
that data and then we take it and we are
storing it in different databases
and then
using various algorithms and various
tools that are available we are actually
doing all these studies which is
actually the omics studies okay
so this is your omics studies which is
your genomics transcriptomics proteomics
and metabolomics so we can say that
it's a
the follow-up that is there is you know
it's like um
the central dogma that's what is there
you have genomics that is the g data so
that then you come to transcriptomics
which is your mrna and other data from
there you have your proteomics so that's
your protein data that you have
then comes your metabolox so i the
ultimately the product that is being
formed is what is your metabolism so i
will lead it uh i will uh
discuss on each of these omics in
details as in where can these be applied
and
what are the different tools that are
available for this so what are the
different kind of studies that that you
can do with different types of mixed
data that is available so definitely you
have to have some kind of an
experimental work only after doing this
experimental work can you go ahead and
do this study which is going to be using
the data that is generated from here
and then the computer and the various
computer
algorithms and programmings are used to
study the data to get some kind of an
output
so omix as i said is a kind of different
technique so that is why it is a very
high throughput technique that's because
whatever data is generated when you are
doing any kind of omics work is very
huge
and it's not possible for any human to
study it in in that details so that is
why you do require
[Music]
some kind of
tools so that is why we use
computational tools now the data that we
that is generally
generated through this hydrogen
techniques would be you can have n
number of genes data be generated you
can find out the expressions that you
have with regards to genes
various proteins that are being
expressed
and also it could be a combination of
any two or three all the three of them
so depending on what kind of study you
are doing that will tell you what kind
of data you are getting in and that data
can be then analyzed using computational
methods which is the bioinformatics part
because the bioinformatics is taking
into consideration the biology as well
as the
informatics it is
combining it to give you
or helping you to solve certain problems
that otherwise would have been difficult
or you can say it could be time
consuming at the same time say for
instance you have generated a lot of
genes
around thousand genes for instance so
analyzing that genes and see
which gene is the most apt it's very
difficult if i say it from human point
of view
using computers that is what becomes
more simplified
so
and uh so omix is basically signifying
the measurement of the entire complement
of a given level of biological molecules
the information that is obtained is
basically
a variety of technologies
and
that helps us to explain
how there is a differentiation that
might exist between say for instance a
normal and an abnormal cell
and when i am talking about the
differences that is there between normal
and abnormal cell i am also talking in
terms of whether it is there is some
kind of a pathway that is affected
whether there is some kind of a gene
expression that is getting affected is
there any kind of a mutation that we
have come across
or whether everything goes good but at
the end point when there is the final
product that has to be obtained there is
a problem with that so whatever the
place uh
which we say before omex all these
is what we can study using the tools and
the databases that are available for
analyzing
things
so why do we use bioinformatics is
obviously because computers
is very much helpful and giving us
faster results along with computers we
also use certain statistical approaches
and that's the best way of starting the
variation
and it helps us to perform
extensive omics related research that
which is present in the biological
database and that helps us to do some
kind of comparative studies
thus at the end it helps us to identify
sequences of proteins that differ
between disease and healthy tissues
so the branches of genome omics are you
have genomics which is nothing but your
quantitatively studying of protein
coding genes
whether you have regulatory elements and
non-coding genes so these are few things
that we study with regards to genomics
then we have transcriptomics that is
your rna and gene expression then is
proteomics which is focusing more on
proteins and metabolomics after proteins
whatever we get as a by-product or as an
end product of any kind of a pathway is
metabolomics and that also indirectly
helps us to study the various pathways
that are involved in that
so it is a clear you can say very much
clear
follow-up from your central dogma from
genes to mrna to dna to mrna to proteins
and then to the
so what can we achieve at the end or
what are the things that we can get
after you you know do any kind any one
ohmic study or a combination of image
studies
you can do data processing
you can identify certain proteins that
are being expressed
you can uh
go away with statistical analysis you do
pathway analysis and at the end you can
also do various type of modeling studies
wherein when i get to know so uh target
identification is also one thing that
can be there when i'm talking about your
pathway analysis
so now focusing on individual
omics that we have so when i'm talking
about genomics we always obviously get
sequences from various
experimental sources and then they are
stored in the databases now you have two
kinds of databases that are available
you have primary database and you have
secondary databases now how they are
different is when i'm talking about
primary database i
simply have done some experiment and
that data is stored in the primary
database
if i further analyze that data and study
has to
say what is its functionality
where is it expressed what is the
situation under which it is expressed
all these things then the information
that can be stored would be the
secondary database from here then we can
retrieve the information so since it is
genomics we tried the sequences that are
available over here and after getting
the sequence we can do various studies
the first thing that you can see over
here is we can do sequence similarity
and this sequence similarity
you have it you can do various types of
sequence similarities over here
okay so sequence similarity would be say
you are doing pairwise alignment so two
tools uh
so you have a sequence similarity which
can be say pairwise alignment wherein i
am trying to see whether the the same
gene from two different species how far
they are different from each other or
how close they are to so what is the one
thing that is varying say for instance
if i am talking about hexafinas that is
present in bacterial genome as well as
in say a plant genome for that matter
so how are the different because the
length of the genome is different
sorry the gene is different so what is
it that is varying that is going to help
me to understand
how there are things that are changing
down the line from uh by evolution and
even though you know there's a change in
the
length of the genes that you are getting
though both of them are for the same
enzyme but still the length is different
so what has changed down the
evolutionary tree because of which even
though it is coding for the same
particular enzyme still my sequence
length is different
or what kind of a variation is actually
existing
the second type that we can do is we can
do multiple sequence align
wherein we can actually again compare
and find out similar genes or similar
enzymes from the same
same species so i have say just e coli
under e coli i have different
sub sub groups that are there so how
these are different from each other a
particular
amount say a particular uh protein is
present in all the sequences but still
what is that that is different at the
genetic level
is what we can do with regards to
genomics and a very frequently used tool
that you have is blast that is used for
doing
or you also have emboss that is used for
your multiple sequence element
the next is gene prediction
we get to find out because we already
have databases that are stored so in
case when you get some kind of
a sequence say after performing any kind
of an experimental work
now by doing uh
searching for those genes that are
present in the database whichever gene
we see that there is a similarity that
is there that is one way in which we can
find out the genes on the other hand we
also have many tools that are available
for example gene parser or eugenes
which help us to find out which gene it
is what is the functionality of the gene
what is this gene coding for or is there
any kind of a difference that is there
in this g
say i have got this gene from some kind
of a diseased person so what is it that
is different from this person and the
normal person for that matter
any kind of a mutation can be studied
using the tool mutation tester
we can study the variation that is there
within the species so n number of
different species that are there we
collect the genes of the similar kind
and that's how we can study the
variations that are existing obviously
we can study the evolutionary relation
that is existing among various
organisms that are present
okay so these are uh different types of
tools that are available for doing their
individual tasks
so
we can at the end what are what all
things that we can do
we can predict
or go ahead and find out biomarkers
we can obtain evolutionary history we
can assess risk management we can also
know about the bioarchaeological
anthropology evolution and human
migrations so it's not just restricted
to any kind of disease related stuff you
can also go about doing a lot of things
over here
like your archaeological survey
anthropological survey or even for that
matter human migrations
so these are the applications
so you can have use the genomic study to
find out molecular medicines and it's
very much uh going to be effective with
regards to doing personalized medicine
then you can go ahead and study
microbial genomics so as uh in the
present scenario you can see that the
gut microbes are
uh you know said to be of
very much you know playing a very high
role in any kind of a disease state
so you can obviously go with the
microbial genomics where you can study
the gut microbes microbes in details
risk management would be with regards to
whether you are
capable or whether there are chances of
you
having a particular disease in the
future
so there are certain diseases that are
genetic in nature certain diseases uh
that you have it from due to the
environmental stress that is there so
you do uh you can definitely go ahead
and do genomic studies to find out if
there is any kind of risk related to
these things
bio archaeology anthropology evolution
these are again
various ways in which we can use the
genomic studies
then you have began a identification
you can also use it for agriculture
livestock breeding and bioprocessing so
in
short what i can say is with regards to
genomics it's
not just restricted to your
disease and non-disease states or things
like that but you can also have its
application in various categories
next coming to transcriptomics so that's
uh transcriptomics means now we we have
the mrna that is available so you don't
have again databases that are there
which can be used where you have the
mrnas that are stored
now what you can do first is you can
find out the exons that are available
or you can directly use the database
that is stored from there you can obtain
the rna sequences and convert them to
your amino acid sequences
after doing that part
you can do again various kind of studies
that are there
you can study the gene regulation
studies so after you get these same
sequences you have um
a lot of genes
so how well are the genes regulated uh
say again here what you're going to
actually do is you're going to take it
from
a set of people who are normal and a set
of people who have some kind of an
abnormality or something which is
different from others
and accordingly we can see
say for instance if i just talk about uh
a situation improved where we had seen
that you know the indian population were
not that much affected as against the
u.s population or the european
population so we could always do this
kind of a study to see what is it what
is one thing or two thing that is
present in the indian population
or absent in the indian population and
vice versa with say u.s population on
the
european population
wherein this kind of discrepancy is seen
you can so this is just one instance you
can have plants that you can see that
they are growing having the same
environmental conditions they are going
in a particular area but they are not
going growing in some other
say country so what is it exactly that
is affecting how are the genes getting
regulated which gene is the one that is
being
regulated at a higher level or regulated
at a lower level
these are the regulatory genes studies
that we can do which can give us some
kind of a solution to solve the problem
that we are facing
at the same time you have gene
expression studies also so again gene
regulation when we are talking what are
the genes that are expressed so many
times it might be possible that it is
expressed but it doesn't go further so
those kind of studies are also there we
can get to know what are the genes that
are
upregulated what are the genes that are
down regulated and that helps us to
understand the
biochemical reactions that are taking
place in the system of one group and the
system of the other group
you can observe mutation at the mrna
level and obviously you can go about
doing the evolutionary variation studies
that are there
so that will help us in prediction of
biomarkers and also help us in searching
for new targets that are help that would
be helpful for drug development
so various approaches or applications of
your transcriptomics approaches are
you have you can do transcriptome
assembly and profiling
you can do small rna characterization
you can do mapping of the metabolites
protein and transit profile
you can
do population breeding studies
and you can do regulation of gene
expressions
so these are the various tools that are
available for studying the trans atomics
data that is available or that we can
get it from the
various experimental techniques that we
have
next coming to your proteomics data
again we definitely will get the rna
sequence from there
we can go about doing the predicting the
uniqueness within a family of proteins
we can predict the structure
of the protein we can study evolutionary
relationship we can observe the sequence
changes that occurs between normal and
disease states that so most of the
applications you can see is quite common
to all the omega studies that is going
to be there it's just that depending on
what data is available to you you are
going to do accordingly
one more thing that we need to keep in
mind over here is as we go down the
ladder from say genomics to pro to
transcriptomics to proteomics to
metabolomics
we are narrowing down so it becomes much
more reliable data the observation that
we see with genomics data compared to
the observation that we see with
proteomics data would be very different
proteomics you can rely more on as
compared to genomics data
okay
so all these things are there you have
you can always when you have the
proteins you can always obtain the rna
strip and then the second is where we
always get the 3d structure available in
the databases
from there we can see we can do any kind
of an interaction studies so if we get
to know say from transcriptomics if we
get to know certain genes you know that
are playing a very important role or
says there are certain genes which are
getting upregulated in a particular
disease so those becomes
those genes become our target
and from there we can if the structure
is available well and good we go through
this protein if the structure is not
available we can do the prediction of
structures
using the information from the
evolutionary relationships or
some kind of uniqueness that is present
in that protein family so this
information as well as the domain
information help us to predict the
structure of the protein and after
getting the structure we can again go
about doing all these studies
okay so when we have the sequence itself
we have the structure itself by doing
functional similarity we can go ahead
and do functional predictions
we can predict the domains within a
family with regards to
the known structure
as well as just through the sequence
so at the end we can find structural
changes for the same gene expressed and
different environment and tissues
so you have
you have one gene that is coding for say
more than one proteins so we can also
see that whether the same gene is
expressed at the same level into
different environments or not or what is
one
environmental conditions or what is one
condition in which it is expressed in
tissue eggs and
in the
change in the condition is helping it to
be getting expressed in say the tissue
wire so those kind of information again
can be gathered through the studies of
proteomics
so again the various applications that
we have is you can go for proteoming
you can go for protein expression
profiling post translation modification
protein protein interactional structural
proteomics protein quantification or
differential analysis and functional
proteomics
thank you dr suchi actually i think we
are running out of time
so if you can conclude the session
yeah so these are the various tools that
are available
then you have metabolomics that is
helping us at the end
and this is also a very important place
where you can
get good prediction of markers because
the initial
you can say the samples that are there
is not something which is going to be
invasive so that's the
importance of metabolomics you can use
just say blood sample urine sample these
samples are enough so we do not have to
go to too much of ethical
issues when we are doing metabolomics as
compared to
genomics proteomics and transcriptomics
so these are the various applications of
your metabolomics so very quickly i just
discuss a small work that we had done
that would probably help you to
understand the omics that is there so
what we had done was we had uh taken few
data sets from your geo ncbi data set
and then applied
geo to r to get
the information that is there with
regards to test and control sample so
our actual work was to uh sort out the
differentially expressed genes which are
ex up regulated and down regulated for
parkinson's drizzies and those who are
tobacco smokers and those who are not
tobacco schools because it was seen
through literature that tobacco is
helping to delay parkinson's disease so
we were just trying to see how this is
affecting the effect of tomato is there
on the express genes so which are the
genes that are being expressed uh
upregulated and which are being down
regulated then those genes we had taken
in david and we had seen what are the
different pathways that they are getting
affected so we had obtained around 17
genes that were there and now we are in
the process of finding out
new molecules you know that are
interacting with these so that we could
suggest some new molecules that could be
helpful for delaying of the parkinson's
disease so that's how we can actually go
about using the whole omics study
using different bioinformatics
applications to get down to the
conclusions
okay so take home message would be you
understand what is omits you understand
the you are able to do personalized
medicine which is very much coming in
the
recent
future
you get to know about the different
pathways involved and the genes that i
expressed and the whole study is
actually very much helpful in prognosis
diagnosis and treatment of any kind of
disease or conditions
and i would like to acknowledge our
director my colleagues
my students and my family members for
the constant struggle and last but not
least i thank the organizers for helping
me
for allowing me to giving giving me this
platform actually to share the
information that i have
thank you